.
HE SAYS THE FED SHOULD PAUSE
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
>> Neil: WE'LL HEAR MORE FROM
OTHER DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR
OFFICE AND WHAT THEY MAKE OF
WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
SAYING.
TO THE LEFT OF YOUR SCREEN HERE,
THIS IS SYRACUSE, NEW YORK.
THE PRESIDENT IS SPEAKING ABOUT
A BIG INVESTMENT FOR MICRON
TECHNOLOGY TO EXPAND OPERATIONS
IN THAT NECK OF THE WOODS.
IT OCCURS ON THE STATEMENT DAY
THAT WE HAD A SURPRISINGLY
STRONG GDP REPORT FOR THE LATEST
QUARTER.
IT'S LIKE WHEN THE EARLIEST ONE
COMES OUT, THE ECONOMY WAS
SPRINTING AHEAD AT A 2.6% RATE
AFTER TWO CONTRACTING QUARTERS
IN A ROW.
THE PRESIDENT SEIZED ON THAT
THAT WE'RE THROUGH THE WORST OF
IT AND WE'RE ON OUR WAY.
KARL ROVE WITH WHETHER THE DATA
SUPPORTS THAT OR NOT.
THAT CAN BE IN THE EYES OF THE
BEHOLDER.
THE ISSUE THAT HE'S CHAMPIONING
RIGHT NOW, THINGS ARE GOING
WELL.
YOU WROTE TODAY ABOUT HOW THAT
MESSAGE SOMETIMES FALLS ON DEAF
EARS AND WHETHER THE PRESIDENT
IS HELPING DEMOCRATS OR HURTING
THEM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> LOOK, THE PRESIDENT WENT OUT
LATE LAST WEEK AND SAID THAT HE
HAD DONE ALL OF THESE GREAT
THINGS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ECONOMY WAS STRONGER THAN IT WAS
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC.
HE LISTED ALL THE THINGS THAT HE
HAD DONE IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
THE QUESTION IS, ARE THERE MORE
PEOPLE WORKING TODAY THAN BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC?
NO.
THERE AREN'T.
THERE'S FEWER PEOPLE WORKING
TODAY THAN WE HAD IN FEBRUARY OF
2020.
IS INFLATION AS LOW AS IT WAS IN
2020?
NO A HECK OF A LOT HIGHER.
ALMOST FOUR TIMES AS HIGH AS IT
WAS.
IS THE ECONOMY GROW SOMETHING
YEAH, WE HAD A NUMBER TODAY.
2.6%.
THE BIGGEST CONTRIBUTOR TO
GROWTH IN THAT QUARTER WAS THE
ROW START OF THE AUTOMOBILE
INDUSTRY BECAUSE THEY STARTED
GETTING SEMI CONDUCTORS FOR THE
AUTOMOBILES THAT THEY HADN'T
BEEN ABLE TO TRICK OUT ANDIT'S
LIKELY TO BE TEMPORARY BECAUSE
THEY'RE BASICALLY GETTING THE
BACKLOG OF ORDERS FILLED.
REAL WAGES.
ARE THEY RISE SOMETHING NO.
18 MONTHS IN WHICH WAGES HAVE
NOT KEPT PACE WITH INFLATION.
SMALL BUSINESSES FORMING AT THE
SAME RATE AS THEY WERE BEFORE
2020?
NO.
CONFIDENCE?
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE ECONOMY
IS LOW AS YOUR PREVIOUS SEGMENT
TALKED ABOUT.
SO THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING,
LOOK, I HAVE IT UNDER CONTROL.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
THAT'S NOT WHERE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE.
IT SHOWS IN HIS NUMBERS.
THIS IS THE REAL CLEAR POLITICS
NUMBERS ON THE PRESIDENT'S
HANDLING OF INFLATION.
34% APPROVE.
62% DISAPPROVE.
HANDLING OF THE ECONOMY, 39%
APPROVE.
58% DISAPPROVE.
IF HE THINKS THIS IS A INWITHING
MESSAGE, WE GOT IT ALL HANDLED,
PEOPLE.
EVERYTHING IS ROSY.
HE'S MISLEADING HIMSELF AS TO
THE IMPACT OF THAT MESSAGE.
FRANKLY THINK SOUNDING OUT OF
TOUCH WITH REALITY TO A LOT OF
VOTERS.
>> Neil: A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
THEMSELVES.
MAGGIE HASSAN BROUGHT THIS UP
EARLIER TODAY WHEN IT COMES TO
ISSUES LIKE THE BORDER.
INCREASINGLY FINDING DEMOCRATS
PARTING WITH THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS FROM EARLIER TODAY.
>> THE FIRST JOB OF GOVERNMENT
IS TO KEEP ITS PEOPLE SAFE.
THAT STARTS AMONG OTHER THINGS
WITH A SAFE AND SECURE ORDERLY
BORDER SO WE CAN HAVE A COUNTRY
THAT ENFORCES THE RULE OF LAW
AND LIVES UP TO OUR VALUES.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
NOT PREMATURELY LIFT TITLE FOR
2.
THERE'S CONSENSUS WHEN TITLE 42
IS LIFTED, THERE WILL BE A SURGE
OF MIGRATION.
>> Neil: THINK ABOUT IT, KARL,
THAT TESTER RACE IN MONTANA,
TALKING ABOUT THE SAME THING,
THE PRESIDENT ISN'T DOING ENOUGH
AT THE BORDER.
YOU HEARD IT OUT OF SENATOR
KELLY IN THE RACE OF HIS LIFE IN
ARIZONA.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
CONGRATULATIONS.
I'M GLAD THAT THEY FINALLY DID
IT.
BUT IT'S ONE THING FOR MAGGIE
HASSAN TO SAY THAT 14 DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
WHERE WAS SHE LAST YEAR WHEN THE
REPUBLICANS WERE TRYING TO ADD
BORDER PATROL AGENTS IN THE
BUDGET AND THE DEMOCRATS VOTED
IT DOWN?
FINE FOR MARK KELLY TO FINALLY
SPEAK OUT AND SAY THE BOREDER IS
A CRISIS HERE.
WHY DIDN'T HE SAY THAT LAST YEAR
WHEN WE HAD THE RECORD NUMBER OF
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSINGS WHICH
HAS BEEN EXCEEDED BY THIS FISCAL
YEAR?
HE'S BEEN SILENT THE LAST 1 1/2
YEARS?
FINE FOR JOHN TESTER THAT FACES
ELECTION IN 2024 TO SAY LET'S DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE BORDER.
WHERE HAS HE BEEN?
THE REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO
GET MORE RESOURCES TO THE BORDER
AND FINALLY CRITICIZE THE
PRESIDENT'S POLICY IN THE LAST
COUPLE DAYS OF THE RACE.
DOESN'T SHOW ME THEIR HEART IS
IN IT AFTER THEY SPENT MONTHS
AND MONTHS OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION SITTING ON THE
SIDELINE QUIET.
>> Neil: IS IT BETTER THAT JOE
BIDEN STAND DOWN, THAT HE NOT BE
PART OF THIS WAVE OF PROMINENT
DEMOCRATS TO HELP DEMOCRATS KEEP
THEIR JOBS OR TAKE THE JOBS FOR
SOME OF THESE ELECTED OFFICES?
I SAY THAT BECAUSE BARACK OBAMA
WILL BE PLAYING A KEY ROLE.
WE'RE TOLD HILLARY CLINTON WILL
DO HER BEST TO HELP OUT.
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
YOU RAISE A COMPELLING CASE
TODAY THAT THE PRESIDENT MIGHT
NOT BE YOUR BEST CAMPAIGN TOOL.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS MYSTIFYING TO ME.
HE HAS TO BE OUT THERE SOME.
IT'S A MIXTURE.
HE'S TRYING TO BE THE CAMPAIGNER
IN CHIEF.
HE OUGHT TO BE THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF MORE THAN HE
IS THE CAMPAIGNER IN CHIEF.
THEY KNEW THIS WAS COMING.
THEY KNEW THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY WOULD HAVE THEIR BIG
CONGRESS.
IF I WERE IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
I'D BE SAYING, MR. PRESIDENT,
SHOULDN'T WE HAVE SOME KIND OF
AN INTERNATIONAL MEET SOMETHING
CALL A VARIETY OF PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD TO CHECK IN WITH THEM
ABOUT THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY CONGRESS OR INVITE THE
JAPANESE PRIME MINISTER OR THE
SOUTH KOREAN PRESIDENT TO COME
HERE SO THAT WE GET THE CHINESE
HAVING THEIR MEETING.
IT'S THE PRESIDENT THAT LOOKS
LIKE HE'S FOCUSED ON
INTERNATIONAL DIPLOMACY, NOT
DOING ZOOM CALLS FOR FUND
RAISERS FOR CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
SO IT'S BETTER FOR THE PRESIDENT
TO LOOK LIKE A PRESIDENT THAN TO
BE OUT THERE AS A CAMPAIGNER
WHEN YOUR NUMBERS ARE LOUSY.
TRY TO REINFORCE THE IMAGE THAT
YOU'RE DOING THE JOB RATHER THAN
SPENDING YOUR TIME MOUTHING
PLATITUDES THAT ARE NOT SINKING
HOME WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND WILL NOT CONVEY A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE TO VOTERS.
>> Neil: REAL QUICKLY.
WE SHOWED SOME REMARKS THAT WERE
CAUGHT ON A HOT MIC OF CHUCK
SCHUMER TALKING TO THE PRESIDENT
ABOUT THAT CONTROVERSIAL SENATE
DEBATE.
BUT EXPRESSING CONFIDENCE THAT
THEY THINK THEY CAN PULL THIS
OUT.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS AN UTTER
DISASTER.
NOBODY HAS EVER LOST A RACE THAT
I'M AWARE OF FOR REFUSING TO
DEBATE.
WHY FETTERMAN AGREED TO THIS IS
BEYOND ME.
TO GO IN AND TAKE THE STRATEGY
OF SAYING EVERY TIME MY OPPONENT
SAYS SOMETHING, HE'S LYING.
SO WHEN HE GOT HIT ON THE ISSUE
OF FRACKING, HE BASICALLY SAID
MY OPPONENT IS LYING.
WHEN HE GOT HIT IN THE CAMPAIGN
ON THE ISSUE OF ADVOCATING A
THIRD OF THE PRISONERS BE
RELEASED, HE SAID HE'S LYING
EVEN THOUGH HE'S ON TYPE 15
TIMES SAYING I LIKE THIS.
IT'S A PROFOUND IDEA.
WE MUST DO THIS.
IT'S AN ODD STRATEGY.
IT STARTED WITH PUTTING HIM IN
THAT MOW SITUATION WHERE NO
MATTER MUCH THEY LOWERED THEIR
EXPECTATIONS, THEY WOULD FIND
THAT THEY DID POORER THAN
WHATEVER LOW LEVEL THEY SET.
>> Neil: IT WAS NOT GREAT BEING
THERE FOR THAT DEBATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, KARL.
WE'RE FOLLOWING SO MANY OTHER
RACES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING NEW YORK GUBERNATORIAL
BATTLE.
IN THE BLUEST OF BLUE STATES IS
ACTUALLY A TOSS-UP OR COULD BE.
LEE ZELDIN, THE REPUBLICAN,
MAKING BIG ADVANCES.
HE WILL BE MY SPECIAL GUEST ON
CAVUTO LIVE.
SHE WILL SAY IT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST SURPRISES OF THIS
MID-TERM ELECTION YEAR.
A GUBERNATORIAL CONTEST THAT IS
AS CLOSE AS A TICK.
WHEN OVERWHELMINGLY DEMOCRATS
HAVE THE ADVANTAGE.
TAKING A LOOK AT BRINGING IN THE
BIGGEST NAMES TO CLOSE THE DEAL
IN THE 12 DAYS AHEAD.
FROM BARACK OBAMA TO THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND INDEED THE PRESIDENT OF THE
THE UNITED STATES TRYING TO PUT
THEM IN PLACES WHE